we're not sure  from a juvenile where my clothes had  holes in them  and my afro is picky to the nighties  moschino and versace no laces in her  cheese  [Music]  the particle that created the universe  [Music]  [Applause]  is  yes  i'm just asking you questions  this is the understanding  and then there's nothing right can you  tell me where's the proof of valor from  nothing  without asking me questions can you  please give me the guarantee  that's the case  this this line here is  yes  can my mother give birth to herself just  give me the give me where's your pokemon  that's what he's doing if you  [Laughter]  i'm  oh  no i'm asking you for proof  thank you  have you ever heard anything so crazy  and  calm down